ciao ragazzi bentornati una nuova
puntata di cucina buttata oggi faremo
una ricetta che già parte come un
insuccesso infinito ecco perché con
questo grande ottimismo che presto a
presentarvi il nostro protagonista di
oggi è lui il feretro rouge un piccolo
bonbon delizioso ripieno di wafer e
crema alle nocciole lo conosciamo tutti
con una volta tolto questo iconico sotto
è scartata questa iconica carta esce
fuori un'iconica palletta accontentarsi
di un morso si può avere un pallone da
calcio di un chilo ecco perché per un
pochino già detto oggi cercheremo di
fare un server uno share da un chilo per
fare un pennello dell'asse gigante
avremmo bisogno di un ferrero rocher che
metteremo da parte 400 g di nuti 200 g
di wafer 300 grammi di nocciole e 300
grammi di barrette alla gianduia arenate
rischiano di cadere ma non cadono agito
agito ma non cadono ringraziamo il sito
butta la pasta è quello che ci ha dato
la ricetta per farli piccoli adesso
vediamo se effettivamente questa la
ricetta può essere tradotte in una
versione giusta
partiamo subito col prendere una
ciotolina a metterla sulla bilancia e
iniziare a pesare i nostri ingredienti
alla nutella questi due sono suoni
bianchi presente che lista tormentano
con la rumore del fondo per mettere con
l'inter e che si aprono e mi svegliai
con modelle che vengono scoppietta te
andiamo adesso a mettere una quantità
che io non ho mai pesato in vita mia
400 g di nutella music beta
beh da 18 beh dalla nutella a questi 400
grammi andiamo ad aggiungere 200 g di
wafer tritati inizia con territori primi
100 300 g di mandorle tostate che noi
andiamo ad aggiungere due secondi la
gran ellin che poi la cosa pazzesca la
frutta secca e che non è per niente se
in realtà noi nel momento stesso in cui
era l'abbiamo distrutta questa qui
sprigionerà un sacco di oli aiuteranno
poi a non renderlo troppo secco perché
uno potrebbe pensare che siano
aggiungendo troppi ingredienti secchi e
invece no queste a breve grondano
aggiungono ragazzi aspetto l'errore
dietro l'angolo ma non io cioè il
problema cerco di la bocca a riprendere
sotto al momento può sembrare una
lettiera una sensazione stupenda ragazze
se volete fargli potete farli piccoli in
realtà è la stessa ricetta se li fate mi
raccomando da katemi ciclista graham ma
nel frattempo se non siete degli stronzi
iscrivetevi a questo canale the tempo
dice il suo è attivata la cappella
notifica praticamente rimanete nella
vostra miseria ma tranquilli un gran
composto gianni però devo chiedere una
mano ho bisogno che mi tiri fuori della
pellicola trasparente cerco di fare la
palla bisogna assolutamente utilizzare
una pellicola che lo aiuti a tenere la
forma così se bravissima el habre
coletta e tutto è tranne che la palla
c'è qualcosa che non mi convince tanto
la facciamo un po rapprendere in frigo
da lasciamo lì per un po che appena si
rapprende la lavoriamo in modo da
renderla tonda 24 ore dopo dovreste
trovarvi una cosa così solida allo
stesso tempo dovreste non ritrovarvi più
un mezzo pero di barba in faccia non
chiedete è per un progetto top secret e
una super figata ma non vi posso dire
niente scusatemi ma bene vi dirò tutto
quanto ignoriamo questo momento e
andiamo avanti
praga lavoriamo veloci prima si riscaldi
quindi tagliamo a metà e poi scaviamo
tipo coca dobbiamo creare i buchi
possiamo dire che questa è una mossa di
salvataggio che stai facendo forse
insinuando che avrei dovuto farlo prima
e non sono identificato siano nostri
salvataggio ragazze che dentro vanno lì
[Applauso]
una mossa di salvataggio anche la tua
prendo l'interno non avrà un pochino una
mano a questo punto operando 24 noci e
cerco di un irr l'era di loro sfruttando
la pasta come se fosse collante è quello
che dobbiamo tenere una palla di
nocciole da mettere al centro
sono ragazze nel frattempo cerco di ieri
compattare tutto ricompattiamo tutto
sancetta fosse un perfetto imbecille che
è andata davvero pensa che facciamo
adesso noi rispettiamo il secondo il
frigo mentre continuiamo con il
procedimento legale sul fuoco sciogliamo
e cioccolato alla gianduia a bagnomaria
spezzettiamo ragazzi ci troviamo in
questa situazione
adesso non ci resta che pregare gesù di
vedere se funziona l'effetto involucro
proprio ti prego crescerà il delirio
tutto quello che non volevamo che
succede se io ho detto che sin
dall'inizio pensato che sarebbe stato
una catastrofe eccola qui momento ruto
critico
dov'è la fregatura sono impressionato
non perché sta succedendo questo
gianmarco non è possibile voci fila
tutto una ragione che la legge sa
qualcosa giro messo in maniera così
irregolare e rende perfetto lo mettiamo
in frigo il mezz'oretta si dovrebbe
raffreddare perfettamente passata allora
dovreste trovare un ferrero rocher in
mano e molti meno capelli in testa
vogliamo passare direttamente
all'assaggio perché è perfetto non è
possibile
anch'io anche secondo va da schifo di
saper h care forza se favore seppure
buono io non so cosa può più pensare
questo si mangia tagliandolo come un
altro
taglianti una tortina non è che lo
mangino un boccone a me non so cosa c'è
dentro questi fatti piccoli vengono
perfetti terra che è una ricetta in
realtà che se farete veramente
velocissima abbia fatto il pallone norme
ma in realtà è una cazzata se è buona se
sei mi piace il modo di assaggio sempre
tutto qualcosa che lo ricorda tantissimo
è la nutella o sembrando al primo
boccone buffon scempio già masticato da
un po che ha il sapore a che ottieni
dopo un po che romanzi e quindi rompi
wafer di una bontà l'interno dell'altra
se ci pensi è un ferrero rocher già
sbriciolato
non sento il va perché vado a rompere
sento tanti pezzetti va per già rotti e
anche più morbida perché non abbiamo
temperato del cioccolato ma anche così
approvato approvato ragazze se lo fate
pagatemi su instagram
e se non lo fate comunque ska vedere al
canale infatti a telecapri le notifiche
e la sua dice un bel pollice del super
che è identico
volevo fare io termine il vostro affetto
chiedere quando sostituirmi non voglio
chiedere niente gianmarco prostituirmi
siccome io voglio rovinare un fatemi
sapere qua sotto questo no altre cose
che vorreste vedere a giganti come
doveva essere tanto a tata gigante
esteticamente perfetto pressionante uno
scontro detto sembra però che ha capito
già sbriciolato sembrano ferrero rocher
sbriciolato dentro lo capisco tutta
l'analisi che hai fatto un sapore quelle
quello è una delle imitazioni migliori
di questo canale ragazzi rest e difatti
piccolini sono loro i complimenti pure
lei ragazzi in ci vediamo giovedì con un
nuovo video e spero più barba ciao
[Musica]